today we are joined by christopher burke
a local personal injury attorney he is
the owner of the patriot law firm and if
you were hurt by a jerk
you better call burke that's the slogan
chris how are things in the personal
injury world right now
hey rocky great to be back uh you know
the patriot law firm is moving forward
ever onward ever upward
we're so happy we get a chance to
represent las vegas valley residents
every single day today we are discussing
a case you recently had against a local
nursing home
related to neglect and abuse right
that's right rocky recently i was able
to negotiate a
six-figure settlement for a family that
had a one of their senior members in
a local nursing home here in las vegas
and it was related to some abuse
neglect unfortunately it was really
related to some bed sores
bed sores that sounds awful what
happened next
well rocky it was awful in this case it
involved a senior citizen that was
admitted to a nursing home that had
mobility issues
now when a senior that has mobility
issues is is admitted to a
nursing care or assisted care living
facility certain precautions need to be
done
they have to make sure that the staff
there may have to make sure that they're
positioning repositioning the
the seniors so that there's not too much
pressure on one side of them so
ultimately this poor senior citizen
suffered some pretty awful
stage four bed sores or pressure ulcers
unbelievable and were you able to
actually help this family
ultimately yes we were and and
fortunately the family actually retained
me
uh within a week or so of finding out
about the bedsore
when that happens we sprang into action
my firm was able to facilitate a
uh and communicate with the facility
about getting the senior transfer to
another facility to get the proper care
that's great i'm happy our community has
an attorney like you to help our seniors
with these types of cases thank you
chris
helping out our local las vegas senior
citizens are some of the most gratifying
that i work on and i'm happy to do so
give christopher burke a call at the
patriot law firm that number is
702-620-2020 or visit their website
at fight for the little guy